two former soccer stars tell us how they
are recruiting others to protect future
athletes Michelle Akers scored both
goals in Team USA's first championship
in 1991 and in 1999 Brandi Chastain
helped lead the team to another title
dr. Jon LaPook
spoke to both of them about why they're
trying to raise awareness of a
debilitating brain disease John good
morning good morning their concern is
chronic traumatic encephalopathy or CTE
it's most associated with football
players who have repeated blows to the
head and suffer from symptoms like
memory loss now these women are helping
to launch a landmark study of former
female soccer players I was the one the
target so I won every punt by the goal
keepers as far as headers went usually
fifty a game I mean a lot oh I did a lot
of heading the ball and it very proudly
so and very determined and very
aggressive two decades after Michelle
Akers and Brandi Chastain celebrated
those championship plays I love you I
miss you every day I don't see you I
miss you even more
the former teammates are still close
friends michelle has suffered from
migraines for decades and both women now
in their early 50s wonder if their
occasional memory lapses are out of the
ordinary when you have those moments
what are you talking about I can't
remember some details of a place we went
or somebody whose last name but then my
friends seemed to reassure me that they
too are experiencing that as people in
my age group so I'm thinking okay maybe
I'm alright one of the difficulties is
how do you determine what's not normal
and what is that's why you participating
in this yes what's just part of normal
aging yes senior moment so called and
what's a problem or what is just
Michelle Akers questions mounted after
she saw a 20-17 documentary by British
soccer legend Alan Shearer who underwent
testing to see if he had any early signs
of CTE I was watching that gone
oh my gosh that could be me it stopped
me in my tracks to help find answers
acres in Chastain have joined a
long-term study into possible cognitive
effects of all those headers and
collisions there at that age now where
if there was going to be some worsening
difficulty this is when we see it
professor of neurology Robert Stern is
leading the new study at Boston
University School of Medicine
but what we're concerned about for CTE
are all of those subtler repeated hits
that we refer to as sub concussive
trauma so this protein goes awry in CTE
the study will follow 20 former
high-level female soccer players 40 or
older baseline testing includes an MRI
of the brain and evaluation of cognitive
function there you go she can take it
forward findings could impact soccer all
the way to college and youth levels I am
concerned that this game played by
hundreds and millions across the globe
might be played in a way right now that
could lead to later life brain disease
that's pretty scary now a youth soccer
coach mother of two and a new
grandmother Chastain is determined to
protect young players from unnecessary
headers I have absolutely done a 180 on
that heading five story punted balls no
not going to happen we're not doing it
while raising her 14 year old son Cody
and cheering on the next generation of
soccer superstars Michelle Akers is
wondering about her own future as I'm
getting older and I'm I want to have
great life I'm planning on that and if
not then I need to like prepare you've
had this huge career and you're at a
point now where you're thinking well
maybe it damaged me in some way yeah
knowing everything you know would you do
it again I would not be heading a
million balls like that there's no way
on earth I would do that again
thief of the world Soccer Federation
says it is actively studying and
monitoring player health saying to our
very best knowledge there is currently
no true evidence of the negative effect
of heading or other sub concussive blows
however Robert Stern told me about MRI
studies that showed subtle brain damage
linked to repetitive heading Wow 50
headers a game I didn't realize it was
that many that's a ton I thought
Michelle raised a good question I think
a lot of people have instances where
they walk into a room and they forget
something or they can't recall
somebody's name how do you know the
difference between a Houston we have a
problem and it's just no big deal yeah
that's the big question Gail right I
mean right now this diagnosis can only
be made definitively at autopsy and both
players have said in a separate study
they're going to donate their brains but
you're exactly right that's the point
I've had times I can't remember names
I've called my son's Ashe which is the
name of my dog okay can you do blood
tests can you do cerebral spinal fluid
announce a new scanning that's gonna
help you get an answer what is what's
your son's name is gonna take a long
time but is there something we know and
can say now for a new soccer for you
sucky you know all the Michelle and
Brandi and Bob all said the same things
which is you know they want people to go
out and do exercise it's healthy but
there are questions we know the most
important part when you have a problem
is first saying hmm there's a question
let's try to answer it that's the point
of this study can I say was great to see
both of there was John thanks so much
see more of John's interviews with acres
in chastain tonight on the CBS Evening
News and for Brandi Chastain tips on
soccer safety go to our website that's
cBS This Morning Calm